you have not been home in days barely
sleep when you are home how many times a
night you like that fist up
I see how much you're pushing yourself
just trying to keep the peace what am I
supposed to do I didn't ask the iron
twist I'm fighting for what I believe in
no matter the cost
what are you fighting for
trying to do what's right I didn't
expect to see you here brother we have
family matters to discuss you in Davos
you were trained together
I fought my brother there is no changing
what happens we feel that you can just
walk through this world as if it belongs
to the iron fist it's not a weapon to be
held it is to be used
so you'll give me also mine brother
you or suffer
the iron fist that was one today
we can stop him but I need help you're
not alone
but you can't save everyone
I can't just sit here and do nothing
I have become insane
you never had the strength to be
history doesn't decide what happens next
why do
we should do this more often dinner out
a movie
[Music]
day night everybody is Charlie we got a
new Iron Fist immortal weapons footage
to break down we got our first shot of
Typhoid Mary she's actually gonna be a
character during season two we also got
some really cool news about Moon Knight
inside the Netflix universe so I'll
explain that too because there were a
lot of rumors after comic-con so if
you're brand new to the channel there's
a new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I named a new winner at the
end of this so I've already talked a lot
about Davos Steel serpent history in the
comics in the ways that he gets his
power but you could probably tell the
way they cut this trailer they really
want you to wonder whether or not he
takes it from Danny ran like he steals
his Chi
or if he gets it from the desiccated
corpse of this dead Iron Fist
and then a lot of you are like wait a
minute did they kill Orson Randall or is
this been here for a long time and
they're just finding it now like has
this older previous version of iron fist
been dead for many many years and
they're just happening upon it in these
tunnels here so I do think that they're
trying to do a little bit of that Orson
Randall Matt Fraction Ed Brubaker story
where like Orson Randall comes into the
story to be sort of an obi-wan Kenobi to
Danny Rand Luke Skywalker and teaches
him about the history of iron fist in
about the history of his family Orson
Randall's family they have all these
underground tunnels and stuff that I
don't think that they're going to be
doing during season two but I think them
in the tunnels and seeing the corpse of
what looks like Orson Randall is just a
reference to that part of the comic book
story so there's a whole bunch of new
stuff that we haven't seen in any of the
previous trailers nailed it you know
typhoid mary probably the new biggest
character if you're not a big comic book
reader she banged daredevil for a while
she's definitely a villain and she was
aligned with the hand for a little while
which is sort of her connection to the
iron fist Lord just because they're the
enemies of iron fist but you probably
remember the actress that's playing her
is Alice Eve from star trek into
darkness she's in a whole bunch of other
stuff but the thing is like she looks
like she's fighting iron fist here
kicking his butt we don't know what her
comic book powers are going to be
because she has a whole long list of
them the really crazy ones are
pyrokinesis and telekinesis I don't know
if she's going to have those during this
series or if she's going to be a total
badass martial artists
with enhanced strength what it seems
like is going on with her in the trailer
is is that you see footage of her
walking with Danny in these tunnels
before they uncover that Iron Fist
corpse but then later they're fighting
in the subway so it might be one of
those bullseye kingpin situations where
like she doesn't necessarily have a lot
of skin in the game but she's working
with joy Meacham in Davos because
they're paying her or she has some
interest in whatever it is that they're
doing they revealed she was gonna be
part of the season way back at comic-con
but they didn't really say what they
were gonna be doing with her during
season two I'm assuming that she will
continue to exist in this universe
because Alice Eve is a pretty decent
actress and Typhoid Mary is a pretty
cool character so hopefully they keep
her around it maybe she eventually pops
up during a future daredevil season the
deal with munites actually pretty cool
he was originally supposed to be a
character during Iron Fist season two
but they decided not to use him so I'm
assuming that he's going to pop up
somewhere in the future but the whole
thing that that confirms is that they
can use the character and he will
eventually pop up because Kevin Feige
name dropped him earlier to like his
quote was something like there are Moon
Knight projects in talked but he didn't
say whether or not there was gonna be a
moon knight movie or if he was gonna be
a TV show like the Netflix series I
think what they're waiting for is just
the right story to use him in so if he
doesn't get his own solo series he will
pop up during one of these Netflix
series in the future the funny thing
about joy Meechum is that you see her
presiding over what looks like a ninja
turtle Foot Clan like as if Davos has
gone full master shredder and is
training his own Foot Clan here but even
though she seems kind of like a villain
this season you see Ward helping her out
of what looks like a big battle here so
we don't really know what's going on
with them because Ward seems like even
though he was a big dick during season
one he's actually the cool guy by the
end of that so he's working with Danny
to try and run the company the way they
cut Davos his voiceover about Danny
giving the iron fist to Davos in the way
they cut all those scenes makes it
really misleading like you see this skin
looking parchment here with the Iron
Fist brand on it but then Davos turns
around with a steel serpent brand on his
back so you're like where did he get
this power from did he steal it from
Danny and did Danny lose the brand when
he stole that because in every fight
scene the Davos has after this where he
lights his fists up for his fighting
Danny you never see Danny light his fist
up so one of two
things is going down here one Davos
could be legit stealing Danny rands
cheese like that's actually a thing you
can give someone your Qi or you can take
it from someone in the comics when Davos
kills
Orson Randall before he dies Orson
passes the rest of his power to Danny
Rand to help him get even more powerful
so I think regardless of how Davos gets
his power they'll explain how you give
and take people's Chi but the other way
he could have gotten it was killing a
previous version of iron fist but even
if this Orson Randall corpse has been
dead for a long long time it just seems
like Danny's gonna be learning more
about the history of the iron fist
they're just deepening the mythology so
whatever way they spin this big comic
book arc I'll try to explain the changes
that they make I am expecting a lot of
comic book changes but we just don't
know exactly what the specific plot
points are but I know I made the joke
about joy Meacham trying to go full lady
kingpin the funny thing about that is
that real kingpin Wilson Fisk
is right around the corner but Vincent
D'Onofrio posted this really cool quote
about his thoughts on Wilson Fisk he's
in a constant state of emergency when he
is not near Vanessa when he cannot reach
out to her touch her he is a walking
talking monument of power emotional rage
leans into him pressing against him
always he is the great white whale of
New York so no matter how many other
villains and any of the other defenders
based series like Jessica Jones Luke
Cage iron fist Wilson Fisk the kingpin
will always be the number one bad guy
and he's also probably the best
performed and best developed villain
that they have inside the defenders
universe let me know in the comments
though what do you guys think about the
trailer footage what do you think about
typhoid mary i know everybody is you
know thinking about them lighting their
fists up the kung fu looks a lot better
they got the fight coordinator from
black panther so they fixed that and i
think they did a better job of pacing
the series out with action like you
think of Iron Fist you think of hardcore
kung fu series so that's what you're
going in for congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner from my last big
video Junior Boyd please email me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for that
spider-man far from home teaser video
and click here and learn all about
Hawkeye Ronin and Avengers 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight